Estonia is an e-prescription pioneer
an online service in the Baltic country
allows patients to get their medication
from a pharmacy without a printed
prescription it's proving a game changer
of both National and international level
after setting up its own system Estonia
began working with Italy this initial
cross-border project didn't take off due
to a lack of funding but then a new
opportunity with Finland emerged thanks
to EU money it meant estonia's Health
and Welfare information agency could put
in place across order e-prescription
service between both countries we
started
operating the cross-border ebrescription
service with Finland in January 2019.
how is it going
by now by Finnish people the service has
been used around 15 000 times Empire
students in Finland it has been used
around 5000 times
a prescription is not only flexible it
also ensures continuity of health care
for people when they are traveling
abroad moreover the secure collection of
this medical data should contribute to
the development of better Public Health
policy
foreign